reid hoffman is one of the most
influential people in Silicon Valley he
found early success and as an executive
at PayPal bridge perhaps best known as
co-founder of the professional social
network LinkedIn he's now a partner to
venture capital firm Greylock and serves
on the board of several big-name
companies like Microsoft and Airbnb
hoffman is also a code developer of the
ethics and governance of artificial
intelligence fun and that's why he's
here today we welcome Reid Hoffman back
to the studio
I love the intro to you read of elder
statesman in Silicon Valley that's like
29 but you said you prefer the stapes
apart it's great to have you here it's
great to be here so you're in town for
an artificial intelligence conference
and I think there are many differing
views about artificial intelligence some
people think great this is way the
future Elon Musk for instance has
expressed some concerns and reservations
about it your thoughts so all there's a
lot of people well all big new
technologies both have opportunity and
threat yeah and and since that's those
are the great ones I mean when cars were
invented people were scared of them okay
they would have someone they regulated
initially someone had to walk in front
of them waving a flag those who know
what would happen so it's always a
legitimate like oh what's the downside
what's the concern and that's real with
a I mean the Aeons very smart however
the opportunities are also great and I
think one of the things is important to
say okay we need to navigate this the
right way but we can actually in fact I
think use AI to create more jobs I think
we can use AI to create do could help
solve disease there's a bunch of things
that it can be instrumental to and we
need to not lose sight of that you say
increased jobs because the fear is yes
jobs are not gonna be taken by foreign
workers but by computers yeah all gonna
be out of a job soon sure that's not the
case well I think it's like for example
broadly all kind of technological
transformations create productivity the
intermediate transition is very painful
right and so we need to make sure we we
do that is that where we are now I think
we're at the beginning of it I think it
will actually in fact get a little bit
worse because the whole stack everything
from autonomous vehicles which will of
course this place a lot of people are
currently driving but well hopefully we
can create new opportunities for them so
for example if you transform space
or what created suburbs you create new
kind of economic centers it could be
construction it can be retail jobs it
can be a number of other things and I
think that's what you're looking for and
and with AI that may actually help us
with what are the ways we can extend
human capabilities so you can do new
jobs
help me out with self-driving cars here
how is that a good idea I actually I'm
afraid of that I have to tell you it's
hard enough with people driving them
exactly well I think that if you even
took technology today and you said all
we had a self-driving cars you'd have
90% reduction in accidents and
fatalities that's a better state than a
worse state you'd have six to eight
times more throughput on current streets
you wouldn't be waiting in congestion
you'd be able to sleep in the back and
drinking and driving which today is oh
my gosh that's a horrific malignant
thing to do you'd be expected to do it
yeah hey you're having a you're having a
beer in the car that's of course it's
fine you're relaxing on your way home
and you won't get a ticket and you won't
get a ticket say you're very comforting
there's an L to say that and I know
there's more to come on this topic we
thank you very much Reed Hoffman for
joining us at the table